hello everyone uh my name is brennan
lucier
today i'm gonna be talking about a model
for buying data over time
um the optimization problems that come
with that uh this is joint work with
nicola morlika
and ian cash
so this talk is about the demand for
data
all right now certainly there's a huge
demand for data
in this current world powered by machine
learning
increasingly we can think of data as an
important input
into the pipeline of product design
right we have large technology companies
that are effectively
building up machinery where you throw in
data into one end
and products come out the other in that
world where data becomes such an
important
part of production it's important to
think about
the actual costs of acquiring it right
and move beyond the idea that more data
is better
and actually think about like if it's a
non-trivial sort of business cost
to actually go out and find and acquire
and uh maintain data we should be
thinking about
like how to optimize that process
now that raises a bunch of questions um
when i'm thinking about some machine
learning tasks
what's the marginal data a marginal
value of having extra data
right how much better do things get if i
get a million more samples
or take a million samples away
also as i'm acquiring data over time and
actually maintaining my products
do i actually need to be going out and
getting new data all the time can i
just use the data that i collected last
month or has it gotten stale and now i
need to collect
more and how much money should i
actually put toward
um having like collecting my data and as
i set different budgets how does that
actually influence
the quality of the products that i come
up with
so all of this was sort of boils down to
a design problem which is you know given
i have a particular use case for data
i'm using it for some particular purpose
there's some costs associated with going
out and getting that data
and i have some budget constraints
what's the right policy
for going out and getting data and
deciding how to spend that budget
and in this talk i'm going to be
focusing on the dynamic aspect of
how should i spread my budget over time
in order to do to collect data
efficiently given that i have some
dynamic learning tasks
that i'm trying to accomplish so let me
start with a motivating example
which is a bit of a toy example but
tries to illustrate some of the points
okay so let's imagine that a politician
is running for office and is running ads
and there's an issue that they've
decided is a very important issue that
they'd like to run ads on
which is healthcare and we can think of
there being a public sentiment
about health care from unlikely voters
um which in this very toy example we're
going to represent as being one
dimensional
you know you spend more on health care
you spend less on health care
so there's some state of the world let's
call say x um
and what the politician would like to do
is they would like to run an
ad that resonates with the public
sentiment
right so they say take some ad which
takes a stance on this issue
and they'd like to get it click that say
that the stance that it takes is
represented by some z
and we'd like that z and x are close to
each other
so the partition is going to say suffer
some loss
which grows quadratically um in this
particular example with the distance
between the
stance they took and public sentiment
now the thing about um public sentiment
is that it can change over time right so
even if the politician sort of knew
what the public wanted one week by the
next week
think something might have happened and
uh things might have drifted you know so
people used to think you shouldn't spend
very much on healthcare
now suddenly people think that you spend
a lot which case they might want to
change their ad
as well over time to sort of track
what the public thinks is a good idea
now the challenge is that the publisher
doesn't actually know what the public
opinion is they can get access to it by
polling
if they poll then they get noisy samples
right by calling people up and asking
what they think
and so given that the actual sort of
aggregate opinion is say x at a certain
given time
if they grant samples they would come
from some distribution which is say
maybe normally distributed around x
and so they'd get you know maybe they
call one person they get something like
y1
they get another call another person
they get something like y2
after getting a bunch of samples they
could then aggregate that information
into a guess at what x is
and then build their their um their
policy in response their ad in response
to that
the thing we want to capture here is
that this polling is not free
right that polling comes at a cost if i
want to set up a polling station
first of all there's some initial setup
cost right to actually build up the
the phone banking and so on and then
when i actually go out i need to pay the
pollsters for their time
so i'm going to incur some additional
cost per sample
and as a politician i have some budget
that i can set aside for my campaign
and i need to satisfy that budget at
least on average
right so maybe some weeks i could pull
more and some weeks i can pull less
but i have an overall average budget
that i have to maintain
now so what can i do um what are my
choice set here well one thing i could
do
is i could you know punt on the whole
issue
run a default ad that doesn't really
take a stance on health care
and then maybe i suffer some fixed loss
just from the fact that
um people out in the world are annoyed
that i'm not taking a stance
right or i could go out and poll
right in order to gain some
understanding about what i think
is the current state of the world
when i do that i know that the state of
the world will drift over time
and an important thing to note is that
even if the state of the world drifts
the polls that i took in the past are
not useless right
they give me some indication of what's
going on but their usefulness will
decrease they become stale as public
opinion sort of drifts further and
further than the state it was at when i
actually took the polls
now the question is given that and given
my ability to sort of play it safe when
i think i'm not
i don't know what really is happening in
the world how much should i pull
and how should i organize it across time
should i
pull a certain constant amount slowly
over time or should i
take specific points and do very
aggressive polling and do data drives
and then sort of free right off of that
information until it becomes too stale
so in this talk i'm going to try to get
at that sort of
setup with a very simple and stylized
version of a data process purchasing
problem
okay i'm going to imagine there's a
state of nature which is one-dimensional
we are trying to estimate given access
to noisy samples
that state of nature drifts over time
and
the decision maker gets to choose a
schedule of when to buy samples
that schedule can be adaptive okay
but it's subject to some budget
constraints
i'm going to make a bunch of assumptions
that are quite simplifying
i'm going to assume that there's no
limit on the amount of data that's
available for purchase at any given time
so the only constraint is the budget i'm
going to assume the quality of the data
samples is uniform
and known to the purchaser okay so
think of it as that you know you get
noisy samples correlated with the state
of the world
and i know how much noise there is i'm
also going to ignore incentive
constraints on the supply side
so i'm going to imagine that when i go
and get a data sample it's actually an
accurate sample
you might imagine that in particular for
this politician polling problem
there might be incentive issues where
the individuals
who are giving me the samples might
misrepresent them i'm going to ignore
that in this talk
and my takeaway from this or the thing
that i'm hoping that you'll take away
is that even in this very simple setting
the this design problem
is somewhat non-trivial um and the
dynamic aspect of it
sort of makes interesting things happen
and so i view this as sort of a first
cut
at what would hopefully be a richer set
of models for which we can understand
uh the issues at play
okay so let me get a little bit more
into details i'm going to warm up with a
static model
that actually doesn't have any dynamic
aspects to it and then we're going to
add the dynamic part in after
so in this static model i'm going to
assume there's this hidden state of the
world
which is again this one-dimensional
thing it's just a real number it's drawn
from some known prior distribution f
and as an agent the decision maker
can choose one of two actions
they can either guess the state of the
world
in which case they suffer a loss that
grows quadratically with the distance
from the true state
or they can pass they can take a default
auction option
which just gives us a default loss of c
and so i can visualize this if i take
this the outside option c
then there's basically no guess right i
get this flat
constant payout right i get a loss of c
but if i choose to guess then my loss
follows this orange curve
which is the closer that z gets to x the
lower my cost is
now before selecting an action i'm going
to observe
samples right so as a as the uh
agent as the person making the decision
i don't know what x is
but i can learn about x by taking
samples right and so each sample is
going to be the state of the world
x plus some mean zero noise drawn
independently across samples
and i want to note that as i take more
samples because my noises mean zero
i learn more and more about the true
state of the world which means that
my loss from taking the guess action
goes down and so what i should imagine
is that as a function of the number of
samples i'm able to take
it becomes better and better for me to
guess
right and so sort of the optimal thing
to do would be if i have too few samples
i should take the outside option because
i'm not very certain about the state of
the world i'm
i'm nervous about suffering a large loss
but as i take more and more samples my
certainty about the state of the world
gets better
and so my loss to taking a guess goes
down
let me make this instantiate a little
more concrete let's assume that this
power distribution is gaussian
and also the noisy samples right the
noise from the samples is gaussian as
well
and we'll suppose that these gaussians
are mean 0 and variance 1.
then in this particular case this very
simple this simple example
we know exactly what the certainty will
be after taking a certain number of
samples
okay so if i took k samples my posterior
belief
will be again a gaussian with some mean
that depends on the
realization of the gap of the samples
and a variance that
decreases as the number of samples goes
up and actually it's exactly 1 over 1
plus k
once i've taken my samples then the
optimal guess will always just be the
mean
and the expected loss is precisely the
variance
these are properties of gaussian
distributions that's why gaussians are
particularly nice to work with in this
problem
so then we can work out exactly what the
optimum policy is as a function of
the number of samples if the number of
samples i took
is small enough that one over one plus k
is less than c
sorry if the number of samples i took is
large enough that one over one plus k is
less than c
then guessing is better than passing and
so i should guess
that's this part down here but if i took
too few samples
so that one over one plus k is less than
c then i should pass and take the
outside option c
and so this is the expected loss as a
function of the number of samples and
certainly more samples is better
okay great so that was a static version
um what we're really interested is a
dynamic version of this game
okay in this dynamic version the state
of nature is actually drifting over time
so now we're going to subscript it by t
and we're going to say that again you
know t1
x1 is drawn from this initial prior
but then every round you know t
increasing um one two three four five
and so on
every round the state of the world is
subject to an extra noise
which we're again going to simplify and
assume is gaussian
mean zero variance one okay so every
round
my state of the world i take a new
gaussian i add it to the previous
um state and so in every round
i can take samples as a decision maker
and i get noisy samples
clearly with the current state of the
world i can take those samples and then
again i can choose whether to guess or
pass
given what i've seen from my samples now
but also given the full history
of all the samples i've seen in the past
my goal is to maximize my average long
run payoff and the thing that i want to
note
is that the samples when i'm thinking
about what to do in time t
the samples that i've obtained in the
past are not as valuable as samples now
but they're not worthless
right because um the state of the world
is drifting over time
but the state of the world around t is
correlated with the state of the world
in around t minus one
so learning a lot about the state of the
world t minus one is actually helpful
for me
in trying to guess what the state of the
world is in round t
and so now we could ask a collection
policy problem
which is suppose that i have an
aggregate budget constraint
right where every round i get given some
sample
a budget that i could use to go out and
collect samples
i could spend that budget immediately to
go get my samples or i could bank it
somewhere all or part of it and save it
for the future so that i can get more
samples later
then what we'd like to do is to solve
the design problem of choosing
a policy that tells me how many samples
i should collect each round
adaptively given the samples i've become
in the past
in order to minimize my long run
expected loss
right which is the limit as t grows
large of the
sort of expected loss that i obtain per
round
and this is subject to a budget
constraint which is that
over the first you know say t rounds i
only have
the per round budget of b times t to
work with so i'm never allowed to spend
more than i've accumulated in terms of
budget up to that point
now i've blocked out the math um of you
know what's actually in this sum
uh i'll show it now it's not important
to sort of parse this
basically this is precisely what the you
know the expected average loss is
in round t given all the samples that
we've observed at this point
and i want to note that my my budget
constraint i want to think of as being
in two parts
all right there's a per sample
cost right so i need to pay a certain
amount for every sample i acquire
will also optionally allow you know the
problem to have a
you know fixed startup cost as well
where
i have to pay a certain amount if i take
any amount of samples more than one
and i want to think about that as like
just the setup cost of putting into
place an apparatus by which to get
samples
background
so how do we solve this problem how do
we come up with a good policy we're
going to use a tool from control theory
called kalman filtering
which is which tends to be used in the
analysis of say
controlling a robotics it's a method of
combining a sequence of noisy
observations
to predict a hidden state which is
itself evolving statusly over time
which is exactly the sort of setting
that we're looking at right now
so for example you can use this theory
to show that
if we took say s samples every round
then the variance
of my posterior will eventually converge
to something like one over square root
of the number of samples that we're
taking
again this is this is depending on us
normalizing so that our gaussians have
variance 1.
in particular this variance is actually
independent of the observed values so
the actions that we would take the
guesses we would make
like it depend on the actual samples we
obtain but our expected loss is actually
independent of the past and this is a
property of gaussians that's
particularly convenient to us
so okay that was for a you know if i had
a particular steady steady state
right if i was just taking a uniform
sampling of s every round
more generally we can use this um this
this feature sort of analyze what would
happen for more general policies
okay so we can imagine a state where um
we start with a particular variance
and we collect samples at a certain rate
and so blue here is we're going to think
of it as the
um as the one over the sampling rate
right so we have a knob which is how
many samples we're taking per round
which can we can think of as controlling
a target point which is if we just took
that number of samples forever
where would we eventually converge to
as we sample our variance right so what
we know about the state of the world is
sort of drifting over time
and will always be sort of converging
towards this point which is one over the
number of samples
and so for a more general policy if i'm
sort of changing
my sampling rate over time what will
happen is that
my variance will always sort of be
drifting towards whatever my current
sampling rate is
right and so we can imagine some policy
which is sort of generally sort of
changing the sampling rate
and we can track its performance by
looking at how the variance would then
drift over time
which is a deterministic function of the
number of samples that we take
to actually understand the value of that
policy we would compare against a
the outside option c and recall that the
available
the option is always available to us to
not actually make a guess
which suffers as cost of the variance
and instead take this outside option
and so for any particular policy
sampling policy like this one drawn in
blue
the actual loss we would suffer would be
whenever the orange line is above the
green line
we would choose to to pass and take the
green line
whenever the orange line is below we
would choose to guess and suffer that
line
and so then our total expected loss is
just the area under this curve
that we draw out
it's useful to think about the value in
terms of how much we're gaining relative
to a very
natural benchmark which is just what we
would get with the default policy of
just never guess
and so i want to think about these holes
these holes in white
as the extra value we're obtaining by
taking our samples and doing something
with them as opposed to just
only taking the outside option every
round
okay so we want to come up with a good
strategy so let's start with a
with a natural benchmark which would be
what would happen if we
didn't do anything clever with banking
and we just spent the entire budget
every round
what that would mean is that we just
sample at a constant rate of b data
points every time period
well this generates a long run average
loss
which is just the minimum like whichever
is better
of the variance i would get by taking my
b samples every round which is 1 over
root b
or c so if one of root b is less
then i'm guessing every round and i'm
getting an average long run loss of one
over
b if c is less
then i'm never guessing and i'm just
taking the outside option every round
and my long run average payoff is c
well okay is uniform sampling optimal
is this the best thing to do well in
general no
um and so in particular it's pretty
clear that if one of root b is higher
than c
so if the optimal choice is to just take
the outside option every round
then we're spending all this effort
getting samples but we're never actually
using them and that seems pretty
suboptimal
and in fact it is if you're in this case
then
certainly one can do better by say
banking by taking very few samples for a
long time
banking up what you've gained
and then taking a short burst of
sampling at a very high rate
to get you below the outside option and
then repeating
if you did this you would get some gain
overtaking the outside option every
round it might be a very small gain
but it is a gain and so certainly this
is better than just always seeing the
outside option which is what the uniform
strategy did
okay fine um but you might ask all right
well
what about the case where actually
when we when the uniform strategy
outperforms the outside option so we're
sampling every round
and we're actually getting um we're
actually guessing every round
is that the optimal strategy in that
case
turns out sort of interestingly no um
you could imagine instead of doing that
we have some strategy that sort of
similar to what we did before where we
sample at sort of a low rate bank up and
then
acquire samples at a more aggressive
rate
afterwards and repeat this gives us some
amount of payoff
which we could compare against the
payoff we would get if we sampled at a
uniform rate
and it's ambiguous which one of these is
better it actually depends on which one
of these two areas is larger
um and in fact you can construct
examples where in fact it's better
to do something bursty rather than do
something uniform
and so sort of our first observations
that even if the uniform sampling
strategy outperforms the outside option
it might be strictly better to use a
non-uniform sampling strategy
right where you actually do these data
runs uh data drives
and so the insight and the thing that
sort of generalizes this beyond this
particular example
is that because there's an outside
option available
data data samples aren't necessarily
substitutes for each other there isn't
necessarily decreasing marginal returns
for data
they're actually complementary up to a
point
okay so if i know that
i'm sort of out above the outside option
um maybe one sample by itself isn't
useful and two samples by themselves
aren't useful but three samples become
useful
and so they're worth more together than
they are apart
um and one can leverage that into
constructing these examples
uh where it's better to do things in
bursts
okay so fine so this uniform strategy
isn't necessarily optimal what are the
approximately optimal policies
well here are some particular classes of
policies to explore
one is what we call an on off policy
which is similar to the things we've
discussed so far so i want to imagine
that
i'm going to have a cycle where i have
a period t which is some number of steps
and what we're going to do is we're
going to take some fraction of that t
steps and we're going to not sample
we're going to start by not sampling for
some number of steps
then it's certain that we're going to
think of that as being off and then a
certain point
in the period we turn on and then we
spend all the budget we've saved up
from the point we turn on up to the end
of the cycle t
so we alternate between no sampling and
sampling aggressively
and we set up the the quantities so that
we actually spend all of our budget by
the
time we get to the end of the period and
we just repeat so this is an on off
policy
i want to consider a more even more sort
of extreme version which is a lazy
policy
where we actually only sample
in in rounds where we are worse than
um the outside option okay so
i want to imagine a lazy policy is a
policy where
um if it's the case that i would prefer
to guess
then take the outside option then i do
not collect samples that round
so this sort of optimizes the amount
that i free ride off of previous samples
which is why we call it a lazy policy
so our first theorem is that these on
off policies are asymptotically optimal
as the period length grows large in the
case where we don't have these fixed
costs for sampling so remember our cost
model was there's a cost per sample
and then a cost to a fixed cost having
any number of samples
if that fixed cost is zero and so all we
have is the cost per sample
then on off policies are approximately
are asymptotically optimal
by which we mean that you know in the
limit as t grows large
um the the uh value obtained
approaches the value of any other policy
and the proof idea is somewhat
straightforward it goes into steps
um first we imagine you know suppose
that there's some region
where an optimal policy has its variance
above c which is to say that the the
optimal policy is not guessing in that
region
because the marginal value of getting a
sample is only better when the variance
is high
it's actually better to sort of not take
any samples at all
and let the variance grow until the
point where we actually want to start
guessing again
and then take as many take take samples
at that point
right and so actually if there's a
period where we're not going to be
guessing
it's better to just be off during that
period not take any samples because any
sampling done there is basically a waste
if the variance is below c then
conditional on being better than the
outside option conditional on choosing
to guess
in that case actually the marginal value
of samples
is decreasing the number of samples we
take and so our payoffs are basically
convex and it's
better it turns out that it's always
optimal
to be uniform conditional on not going
outside um
not choosing the outside option so in
the region
where we're choosing to guess it's
better to keep a constant
rate so you can show more formally that
given any policy you could reallocate
samples to make them more uniform and
this is only helpful
our next theorem is that you know more
generally if we allow this
this z parameter to be bigger than zero
um
so if we do impose a fixed cost to
taking samples
then lazy policies are approximately
optimal in the sense that they always
achieve at least half of the optimal
gain
relative to the world where
we just take the outside option every
round
and so here's a visual here's the
intuition for that proof visually
consider the optimal policy suppose this
blue curve
is sort of the optimal policy
um that what i'm drawing in this blue
curve is the variance
you know so i'm sort of tracking the
variance
now remember that the optimum right so
the thing we're trying to approximate
is the holes like the difference between
the variance of our optimal policy
and the outside option curve we could
draw a bunch of squares like this
and the area covered by those squares is
an upper bound on this optimal value
certainly this covers these holes
but we can obtain half of that value by
taking a lazy policy
where at every point if we're sort of
starting a new square
we sample as much as we can to sort of
get down
to the bottom corner and then we don't
sample anymore
which causes the variance to drift up at
a constant rate
so there's a lazy policy that gets
precisely these
blue area here which is at least half
the area of the squares which is an
upper bound on the value of the optimal
policy
so let me sum up um this stock we
introduced this very
simple sort of model which exhibits some
non-trivial optimization with respect to
how to collect data
it's you know it it models this
particular problem of trying to learn
the state of the world with quadratic
loss
um and we show that even this simple
problem the marginal value of data is
not monotone
if we have this notion of having an
outside option right so this we can
think of this as different modes of
usage that we're deciding between
and this can lead to a strict preference
for collecting data in bursts rather
than collecting it uniformly over time
okay where to go from here more
generally we'd love to use this to think
about
insights and best practices for people
who are optimizing a collection of data
in more general problems right beyond
these gaussian issues what about like
multi-dimensional regression
and and you know even like deep learning
um
what's the marginal value for data and
how should we think about collection
also we'd love to you know build out
into um
into into broader classes of problems
with supply constraints
um what if there are incentive issues i
think there's a rich space of open
problems there
to try to understand to what extent
these insights carry over
in more realistic and fleshed out
environments
and with that i'll stop thank you very
much
you